now at the beginning of that interview
we heard a little update from Dominic
Raab about coronavirus a small group of
Britons who didn't make it on to the
first evacuation flight out of China are
now returning to the United Kingdom
joining us from Leicester is the shadow
health secretary Jonathan Ashworth to
discuss the outbreak and so we're just
hearing there about the second group of
British nationals returning to the UK
and we have also had the first confirmed
cases of corona virus in the United
Kingdom what do you make of the
government's response
well actually unusually for me Sophie
coming on your show where I usually come
on your show to attack an element of
government weakness in policy I'm
actually going to praise an HS England
and our public health specialists I
think they are doing all that they can
in the circumstances and obviously our
thoughts today must go out to those who
are on the plane who are in quarantine
and those those who have contracted the
virus but of course all that brilliant
NHS staff who are working around the
clock on this issue so unusually for me
I'm not going to sort of criticize or
undermine the government efforts I think
they are doing everything they can be
doing I think probably they need to be a
little bit quicker at getting
information out particularly in the
areas particularly in York particularly
on the world I know there are people
concerned on the ground and in the
general public but I generally I think
NHS England and our public health
specialists have have responded in the
correct way to this very unusual moment
on a political interview show I think
you're probably right there and how
worried do you think people in the UK
should be about coronavirus I just
wonder if there's a risk of scare
mongering I mean there's only two cases
confirmed in the UK the death rate for
the infection is just 2% far less and
things like SARS or a bola are we
getting a bit over concerned well I mean
we don't want to go among rings but
everyone should be vigilant I mean this
is a very infectious virus there's no
question it's extremely infectious more
infectious and SARS I believe but the
mortality rate is around 2% in other
words 99% of people will survive this
and will and actually a lot of those
people will have relatively mild
symptoms that it's not to undermine the
seriousness of it
and we should all remain vigilant but
that we don't need the sort of some of
the scare mongering that we've seen in
some of the newspapers about it
and I think the advice today that's come
out from the NHS around washing your
hands disposing of tissues being careful
is the correct advice we all need to be
vigilant because this has got some way
to go yet and as I say it's extremely
infectious this virus and we could see
it spreading quite rapidly further but
we should just all remain vigilant
you're focusing their role and how
infectious the virus is as you say it's
an extremely infectious virus which just
brings me to one of the images that I've
struggled to kind of get out of my head
in the coverage this week which was
those coaches bringing people from Wuhan
to the health facilities well that we
put in quarantine the health workers
were in full protective gear but the
drivers of those coaches were wearing
ties and shirt sleeves and the Sunday
Times this morning saying that horsemen
coaches apparently secured protective
suits for the drivers but we're told
categorically by the government that the
drivers were not allowed to wear them
and you bit worried that the drivers of
these coaches have perhaps in somewhat
overlooked I mean I saw the photos and I
can see that the first host looks very
alarming didn't they but actually when
you read it when you look into it the
the advice that the clinical advice is
that if the drivers had worn the
protective suits that that could have
caused them problems and driving and
they thought on on the balance of
probabilities it was more important that
they could drive the coaches well and
not have any accidents on the coaches so
that all these things we have to take
the medical advice on and and I don't
think I'm not seeing any evidence that
government officials or health officials
are not following the medical advice
okay and thank you very much for that
I'm keen to move on to brexit now first
program post and membership of the
European Union you of course campaign to
remain so what were you doing 11:00 p.m.
on Friday night were you drowning us or
surahs oh I was in bed I like to be in
bed about half-past ten that most nights
so I was
celebrating or drowning my sorrows I was
getting on with my life I mean it's
happened now I mean I mean well it's
happened doesn't it I mean I was a
remaineth this part of the world where
where I'm stood today voted remain but
leave one and now I hope this division
between levers and remainders can come
to an end and we just can pull together
again and move on that means we still
got to scrutinize the government and
were still skeptical about some of Boris
Johnson's bland claims about what he's
going to be able to deliver in this post
brexit world but the issue itself has
been settled now we've just got to make
the best of it we spoke to the Foreign
Secretary don't rob and the head of your
interview Boris Johnson's can be setting
out his vision for our post brexit
relationship with the EU tomorrow it's
pretty clear that they want lots of
divergence they don't want to be
aligning too much with the European
Union are you worried about what this
looser relationship could look like well
presumably tomorrow he announces 450
million extra a week for the NHS of
course look that we all see what he has
to say we think it's important that we
have a close relationship with Europe we
don't want to see any watering down of
the environmental standards the
workplace rights that we've won the
consumer rights that we've won over many
years through our membership of the
European Union but we'll see what he
says and that I know that Boris Johnson
has a thumping great majority in there
in the House of Commons how could I not
know that but that doesn't mean we won't
hold him to account that doesn't mean we
won't put him under careful scrutiny and
he's made some big big promises to the
British people not just on brac sir he's
promised us 40 new hospitals 50,000 new
nurses for example we will hold it be
holding him to account on each and every
one of the promises he made to the
British people in that recent general
election but if he does deliver on that
in some of those red wall seats in the
Midlands in the north of England then
labour can have a real fight trying to
regain them well yes and we but we're
gonna have work the next general
election when it comes is going to be a
difficult general election I mean we got
thumped didn't we we got absolutely
smashed in our general election we lost
seats like Northwest Durham like bowls
over
seats we've held forever and Sikhs that
we thought we were going to gain where
we'd pioneered new campaigning
techniques like Mansfield like Hastings
we went even further backwards so labor
has a problem and it's partly because
the structure of the labor vote has been
changing over ten years we still do
extremely well in cities like the one I
represent in in university towns in
areas with which are very diverse yet in
are very traditional areas but Bolton
Barry you know bowls over and
northwestern room we've lost seats and
gone backwards there's gonna be a few
years for the Labour Party to win
people's trust again it's interesting
they're talking about the performance in
the election and because she's sort of
coming didn't you
there was a looped recording of you just
before the election where you said it's
dire for labour outside of the city
seats it's abysmal out there they can't
stand Corbin and I think neighbors
brought blocked brexit so you were right
all along well I mean the tragedy of
that phone call isn't the personal
embarrassment it caused me by being sort
of manipulated by a former friend but
indeed the general election result was
much worse than my exaggerated attempts
to placate a former friend on a phone
call I mean we lost seats like Northwest
Durham and Bowles over which have been
Labour through and through forever and
as I say it's partly because the
structure of the Labour vote our core
vote has been changing over 10 years
this hasn't happened overnight
we lost Scotland in 2015 many sort of
cult former coal mining areas actually
went in 2010 them I mean Sherwood is a
Nottingham sure coal mining seats and
there's no pits anymore of course but
was a nothing in Shekhar mining seat we
lost that by 200 votes in 2010 in this
last election we lost it by about 16,000
votes so these trends have been
happening for some time but the
challenge for labour is how do we
maintain our strength in cities like
Leicester and inner city London and in
university towns while rebuilding in
Barry in Bolton in bowls over the
northwest Durham that is the challenge
for our candidates who are running for
leader you say that some of those
problems for labor have been a long time
coming but some of them were more recent
some of them were mistakes around the
election campaign as well and one of
those people very closely associated
with that campaign is Kay Murphy Jamie
Corbin's chief aide also has bullying
allegations against her that she denies
her lawyer had deniers very strenuously
is it right that she's been nominated
for a peerage well it's the progress of
the leader or low party John McCord is
it right who is it but here we think
well I mean all leaders put forward who
they want to before but there will be a
I don't know the ins and outs with these
allegations but there's always a process
there's a vetting process so it's an
independent process that will look at
these issues I'm an independent process
we'll make a decision on whether the
people on that list will go in by the
way I'm I have no idea who Jeremy Corbyn
is I put in I'm just assuming that the
names that have been in the media are
the ones he's put in by the way but
there will be an independent process
which will look into all of these
allegations now looking ahead to the
Labour leadership race you're supporting
least nandi's a candidacy to be the next
Labour leader kind of help but notice
that she's the only person in the race
still he wasn't a member of the Shadow
Cabinet does that mean you think it's
time for a break from the Corbin project
well I think the policy agenda that we
put forward the last election with the
correct agenda
because because the challenge for labour
is I've talked about about these
problems we've got between our city
areas in our university towns and our
traditional heartland but when you look
at the challenges facing people in those
areas in both areas the universal credit
is seeing child poverty rise in both
areas people have got difficulty
accessing good schools a good NHS
difficulty accessing good housing they
want their streets to be safer and we
actually put forward a set of policies
which would meet those challenges in
both areas so when you say a break from
the Corbin era you know that's the sort
of sort of I don't mean it to be rude to
you but slightly simplistic way of
looking at it the policies we put
forward I think are a good set of
policies now over the next few years
we'll have to develop policies for the
2025 to 2030 period so some of the
individual items might not may not stay
in the manifesto because we're dealing
with the second half of this decade but
broadly policies which are
anti-austerity a real issue about
investing in public services which were
about delivering economic justice a fair
taxation system there that's there the
correct policies so you need to be put
in CDs people in the coming years if the
policies that the right ones why is it
then that you're backing the wrong
candidate who wasn't in the shadow
cabinet who wasn't part of drawing them
up because I think what least an
underused me the shadow cabinet and
actually when she wasn't the shadow
calendar began the developer and then
she was a lot of our green agree oh yeah
but a lot of our green policies I mean
we talked today about the green new deal
and I remember Lisa Nandi talking about
list of five years ago because she was
ahead of the curve on it but you know I
mean I'm supporting least nundi because
I think she was one of the first to
recognize these problems in our
traditional areas before perhaps some of
us did in the Labor Party and was
talking about that but you know that was
I wouldn't say that just because she's
you know one of the others one for
example I would support what on the
others as well I'm not going to say well
they were they were in the Shadow
Cabinet so they count with a little over
party but fundamentally though the
members will decide this it's not really
up to me it's up to the members and
they'll they'll all they'll consider all
these candidates very carefully you
talked about Lisa Nandi being one of the
first people to articulate that break
perhaps between what Labour's
traditional voters wanted in some of the
working-class areas and some of the
towns in particular do you think the
Labour Party has become too metropolitan
perhaps a bit too liberal
well I'm not sure what that actually
means because that there they're
slightly pejorative terms or can be
interpreted as slightly mature from the
pejorative terms it's certainly true
that the Labour Party is very strong in
cities and metropolitan areas and has
become very weak in suburbs and towns
and former industrial areas and that is
the challenge for us in the coming years
how do we hold on less dirt and
Nottingham to to inner-city London to
Liverpool while winning back Barry and
bolter and Hastings and Swindon I mean
that is a big challenge and and
something that is going to involve a lot
of hard work over the next few years
okay
Jonathan ash well thank you very much
for being on the program this morning